Lauren Bushnell flaunts major PDA with  new boyfriend  Devin Anton yes you don't know now you  know the 27 year old former bachelor  winner made it Instagram official with  her new man over the weekend posting  this sweet snap cozied up to the 28 year  old real estate agent captioning the pic  dibs lauren also shared this sweet  moment of the pair ET spoke with the  reality star at soul society's toast  friends and fall fashion event last week  where she opened up about her budding  romance I'm very protective over it  because it's someone that I've known for  a while and we had a friendship  established before I even went on The  Bachelor when you go through a breakup  for me at least that was the last thing  on my mind I wanted to just take the  time to like take a deep breath so it  wasn't necessarily planned but I'm very  happy and yeah hopefully it all works  out I don't know we'll see we're working  together which has been really fun  [Music]  Oh